okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of history of science and
technology q a
uh sorry we're starting a little late a
few bizarre technical problems here
um
all right we had a
whole bunch of questions saved up from
last time
um the question from slayer here what
did doctors learn from henrietta lacks's
cells
okay i can try and talk a little bit
about that i don't know fully the
history of this
first point
is
there's a
when biological organisms grow
one of the key things that happens is
cells divide
and there's a question if you have a an
organism and it's growing how long does
it grow for do the cells just keep on
dividing forever
or is that is there a limit reached
where the cells stop dividing where they
kind of know the organism is sort of
fully grown or something and where you
just stop dividing cells
and there's some organisms some more
primitive organisms where they just keep
dividing and they just keep going and
they keep growing out and you know back
in the i don't know pre-cambrian period
there are big mats of uh organic
material that probably were formed um
that just kept growing forever
as we get more sophisticated and as we
make uh things like uh
you know higher animals and so on it's
like we grow for a certain point at a
certain time and then we stop growing
and then maybe we have children and then
they grow and so on but but there's a
limit to growth
now you just imagine the kind of whole
tree of cells in a biological organism
in the sense that you're starting off
from the single you know
uh like fertilized egg cell and then it
divides into and then that divides to
four and eight and so on after a while
it becomes more complicated and it's no
longer every cell just dividing into
it there's some cells that are more like
stem cell like things where it's like a
cell keeps on butting off new uh new
other cells there are others actually
that's not the meaning of stem cells
more something where you can get uh you
can plury potent stem cells where you
can where you can get to all other cell
types as you as you look at this kind of
sequence of dividing cells eventually
you'll get a cell that's a bone cell or
eventually you'll get a cell that's a
immune system cell or something and then
there is a
at some point you'll get sort of all the
cells in the final organism but there's
this kind of whole hierarchy of what
cells can divide from what other cells
okay
so
one of the questions is how does cells
sort of know to stop dividing and there
are typically chemical signals that tell
cells okay there's enough of you stop
stop dividing now um and
there's but there's a another phenomenon
that
probably has quite a lot to do with
aging for example that if you have a
particular cell and it keeps dividing
and dividing and dividing and dividing
and so on that there's a limit on how
many divisions you can have and that
limit it's usually called the hayflick
limit
is on the order of 50 divisions
and
the uh
so once you have an initial cell the
maximum depth of the tree is essentially
50 nodes that's the maximum so the
maximum size of the organism would be
like 2 to the 50th
cells or something um that
would be that would be determined by
this um
uh this this maximum number of divisions
that you can have
there's some
suggestion that that maximum number of
divisions has to do with the telomeres
the the ends of dna that are these
repeating sequences and that you kind of
start with on the order of 50 of those
and they seem to kind of get dropped off
every time cells divide obviously they
have to get refilled again
when the next generation of organism
comes around and there's some and
there's also i don't remember all the
details of it but there's a enzyme
telomerase that is responsible i think
for for adding on telomeres and i think
it's kind of like i because i always do
all these crazy things you know i went
and sent off my my dna to some place
that will measure telomeres usual dna
sequencing doesn't do so well with those
repeating pieces because the way that
dna is reconstructed involves sort of
solving puzzles which require that you
have different
uh
different
um
elements in the sequence to be able to
see how the puzzle goes together and
when there's something that repeats that
too many different ways that the puzzle
could be assembled you can't really tell
how it works
anyway there are ways to measure
telomere length
and so you can kind of say well how old
am i you know as i gradually age and
divide my cells divide and so on am i
using up all my telomeres
and at which point at the end after all
the telomeres are used up the you know
the dna might just sort of unspool
itself because it doesn't have the right
end caps on it and it's said but of
course the the you just lose telomeres
as you age your cells to divide isn't
quite the whole story because you know
it's like well if you eat better and
exercise better and so on you can end up
with more telomeres and it's not clear
what exactly the telomere length is an
indication of but perhaps it has
something to do with this hayflick limit
of maximum cell division
um
the
so okay so that's that's the typical
behavior of cells as they divide for a
while they either get signals from other
cells saying we don't need any more
cells in this area stop dividing or they
hit this hayflick limit and and stop
dividing that's how normal cells work
uh tumor cells not work that way that's
in a sense almost the definition of a
sort of malignant tumor is that it
doesn't accept those signals from other
cells it doesn't accept this limit of
don't divide any more after this after
this point
and so in a sense you know tumors are a
sort of more primitive form of life than
the one that uh we normally enjoy so to
speak
well
so if you are trying to do experiments
on human cells and you say well i've got
the cell and i want to make a cell line
that is i want to make lots of copies of
the same cell so i can do sort of
reproducible experiments because i've
got lots of the same cell
the um
it was um uh
that's hard to do with an ordinary cell
ordinary human cell because if you say
you put it in cell culture and you say
okay cell just go ahead and divide
divide divide divide after a while it
will hit this limit and it won't divide
anymore and so that cell line will you
won't be able to go on using that
however if you use a tumor cell then you
can keep you can just keep it dividing
and dividing keep going and keep going
and you get lots and lots and lots of
copies of the same cell
so back sometime in the 1950s
there was a woman named henrietta lacks
who um had some type of cancer i can't
remember which kind um and
as part of treating her
the the um a sample of this of this
tumor was biopsied and that those cells
were grown in cell culture and those
became the standard kind of cells
they're called hela cells hela cells
that are used in gazillions of
biological experiments
and um uh unfortunately the the uh you
know the state of of um
of medical ethics was was not as it is
today
and uh i'm not even sure
when
uh henrietta lacks or her descendants
even found out that those cells were the
the big thing used in medical research
i'm not sure how many decades that took
um it's
a different uh that that that whole
story has changed since then but any
case from the point of view of
biological experimentation
it's been very useful that there's a
definite cell line that you can kind of
just order you know cells from that cell
line and do experiments with them and
it's sort of an attempt to have a a
standard uh sort of sample
cell
form for a standard human cell that you
can do experiments with it's kind of a
little bit like
saying what's the standard human genome
um you know it's there's everybody's
genome is different everybody's cells
are different but it's useful to have
some standard that you can use as a
basis for doing experiments
and one can certainly ask the question
well
this particular uh cell line that came
from a tumor from sometime in the 1950s
and so on from some particular person
with you know some you know you go look
at that that cell and you go find the
dna of this particular individual and
and you know you can find the um uh the
you know no doubt you can go find the 2x
chromosomes and all those kinds of
things and that'll be different from a
from a cell with x x and y chromosomes
and so on but in in medical
experimentation there's
great value to having repeatability of
yes we've got the same kind of cell
uh even though that cell may not be
typical of all cells and it may be that
there are things that you can do
that are sort of potential um kinds of
uh tests of of medical things
that uh if you could do them on a wider
diversity of cells it'd be better but
the um that particular there's there's
value in being able to compare different
things and so having a sort of standard
cell line and that's so that's the
that's the story as as as far as i know
of of of the gila cell
line let's see
uh
okay there's a few questions here which
i can partly answer there's one from
varmanity he's asking about the higgs
boson controversy
oh boy i haven't seen this controversy
it says many physicists are saying they
fudged the numbers to get more funding
oh boy
yeah well experiments are hard you know
these big experiments are really hard
i have to say
that
the question of okay
the best case when you do experiments is
the effect you see is so dramatic so
obvious you're not grunging around
trying to do statistics and you know
trying to tease out this you know two
sigma effect over this and that and the
other
i mean i have to say
that
often
in these big experiments where you're
teasing out a small effect you can ask
you a very common thing is
particularly in something like a
particle physics experiment it's like
you get some number of particle events
and you say
uh from that i need to deduce what
fraction of the time did this happen
well that may be very hard to figure out
because is each particle event is its
own separate snowflake so to speak its
own separate thing where the particles
went in this direction that direction
and so on you have a detector that's
measuring
you know where the particles went it
might be something where there's some uh
you know a particle goes through in this
direction some tube fires
and uh or some semiconductor detector uh
records a voltage in that particular
direction so you know a particle went in
that direction
and so then the question is
uh you've got
you've got the actual events that
occurred however many there are millions
of them maybe maybe more um and you've
then you've got what the theory says
should happen and the theory again
says oh well there's certain probability
for different events and so on now you
have to do some kind of inversion so you
have to say given the theory what would
we expect in the experiment then given
what we observed in the experiment what
does that back imply about the theory
that's a hard thing to figure out
and it's fraught with mistakes and i
know when when i was working in particle
physics in the late 1970s
that was a time when people were really
first starting to do these very
complicated kind of monte carlo bayesian
inference type things on figuring out
given what you observed in the
experiment what does that back imply
for what the theory must have been
and certainly when i was involved in
this particularly in the in the
discovery of the gluon which i was
rather deeply involved in um and i i put
it in kind of sounds like quotes because
it was a messy story very messy story
where the full structure of quantum
thermodynamics of theory of quarks and
gluons applied many things you could
check a lot of those things but if it's
like i want a smoking gun i want to see
a gluon gluons like corks are
permanently confined inside particles so
you don't get to see you know pick up a
uh you know i've got a bottle of free
gluons or something it's a more
inference
inferential kind of thing and so it's
it's difficult
to do that and certainly it wasn't the
case that you could find the very
obvious i've just discovered a glue on
it's here look at it i can see its track
in my experiment type thing was a more
complicated inference and you know when
i was involved in it it was it was it
was in many ways done shockingly wrong
and yes it was a case in that case for
example there were particular you know
like people accelerator labs and so on
which wanted to be the place that would
be sort of recorded in history as the
discovery place of the gluon and uh you
know there's a lot of kind of
complicated organizational jockeying and
uh the science i i kind of felt almost
becomes a secondary type thing in that
type of situation so i don't know i
don't know the story of of um
the uh
uh whatever's happened right now with
the higgs boson but i just say these
experiments are hard and it's uh and the
question of when do you say here's
another another issue another issue
which uh is you're doing an experiment
you do all these different kinds of data
analysis eventually you find a signal
okay do you stop at that point or do you
keep going and you say well if i done my
data analysis yet another way would i
have found a signal or not and you know
you had four different ways to do your
data analysis one of them found a signal
but maybe that signal is sort of a well
if you've done it one of the other ways
you wouldn't have found a signal and
maybe it was sort of a fake because you
went on until you found a method of data
analysis that gave you a signal is it a
fake is it not a fake it's complicated
and
i would say that this is one of my fears
actually as we look towards experimental
uh implications of our theory of physics
is
that it becomes kind of complicated to
know you know when do you do an
experiment the experiment is very hard
you know what are the sort of uh what
are the expectations
of how you know if if you want to do the
experiment and show that the effect does
not occur
you just
do it
and you don't keep on doing those
analyses until you can actually tease an
effect out of the noise you say oh it's
all noise there's no effect
and
you know you can say well that's bad
science
but
you know at some point i mean it's it's
it's hard to know when do you stop
you know i think this happened for
example with the with things like the
cold fusion business
it was like there were experiments done
they were hard to reproduce people said
oh the effect can't be there
well
the question of why were they hard to
reproduce maybe they were hard to
reproduce because the only way that you
get that effect is when
the when you're not at sea level because
it depends on having extra cosmic rays
which we didn't know mattered or when
some other you know when the lab
when the lab is all dark because it's
destroyed by light or you know lots of
different kinds of things where it's
very hard to know what was the effect
that actually mattered and as you try
and think about doing those experiments
you say well i don't see anything i
don't see anything i don't see anything
well did you try
making it brighter did you try moving it
to denver did you try doing this well at
some point you just say no i i tried all
the reasonable things i could try i
didn't see anything therefore there is
no effect
is it really true there's no effect hard
to know so it's difficult
and you know i'm afraid this is people
always say you know experimental science
is all about just you do the experiment
you see what happens that's how you
conclude what's true in science it does
not work that way in practice it's much
more complicated there's much more of an
interplay between what you expect to see
how you do the experiment how you
interpret the experiment all those kinds
of things um and while people would like
to look to science for sort of the
ultimate cut and dried answers uh it
doesn't tend to work that way which
works a lot better with computer
experiments computer experiments are
much more cut and dried just like sort
of pure mathematics is in many ways more
cut and dried until you get into the
question of is that proof really a proof
type thing um and uh but but that's it's
you know that this is the difficulty of
of actual experiments i mean another
sort of the fundamental sort of idea of
experiments is
you can do an experiment
which in which you carve out of the
world something which is an isolated
thing where you can just do your
experiment and it doesn't depend on
anything else
and that's probably theoretically
impossible that is like i was saying
before you know you're doing your
experiment on your palladium electrode
or something for cold fusion and you say
i'm just working on that it doesn't
matter that the air temperature is this
it doesn't matter that something from
the outside world is this i can do an
isolated experiment that may just not be
possible in in some theoretical sense
and in fact as we look at our theory of
physics we can see that there are things
where in fact just yesterday i ran into
something trying to uh look at some
results someone else had got of
realizing that it actually matters when
you're studying this this system or you
think you're studying some system about
gravity uh with black holes and all this
kind of thing it's like what's on the
outside of this it actually matters you
can't just isolate it and say i'm just
going to look at this part of the system
and nothing else although that is the
kind of meta
claim
of sort of baconian type science is you
can do an isolated independent
reproducible experiment um so it's hard
thing to do now in terms of of um
uh
the higgs boson and so on yes i i did
meet peter higgs who are asking that um
maybe
well let's see a couple of times i
remember one time
uh
in edinburgh actually where he lived um
the um
uh
you know i think um
back in the day
i mean just to give a little bit of
history here
and somebody asked about steve weinberg
uh who who died a couple weeks ago now
uh yes i i did know steve weinberg um
the um
and that sort of as we talk about peter
higgs and steve weinberg i'll i'll tell
you a little bit more of um of that
relationship um
it used to be the case that what's now
called the standard model of particle
physics was basically what used to be
called the weinberg salaam model
and uh how did that originate
well let's see the um
sort of
the big thing
that
they're sort of in in particle physics
they're these sort of often said to be
sort of four fundamental forces the
strong nuclear force
that kind of holds quarks and gluons
together and holds atomic nuclei
together
the the weak nuclear force that's
responsible for beta decay and that all
has to do with w bosons and things like
this
the electromagnetic force have having to
do with photons and electricity and so
on and gravity
and sort of the standard model is the
story of what particle physics has
learned about sort of strong weak
electromagnetic forces
so back in the day
this is now
um so electromagnetism
uh the quantum theory of
electromagnetism
was kind of first proposed really in the
1920s
and really got worked out in the 1940s
that's the theory of quantum
electrodynamics
the original idea when quantum mechanics
originated um sort of things like
schroedinger's equation and things like
this originated in the 1920s
the issue to deal with electromagnetism
was you can change this equation deals
with i've got an electron one electron
maybe two electrons i've got one i've
got a few particles in a field like an
electromagnetic field you've got the
idea of photons where you don't have a
fixed number of photons you're just
producing photons virtual photons to
represent sort of pieces of the field
and you're producing lots and lots of
these and the number of photons can
change
and so that
needed a field theory rather than
quantum mechanics it needed quantum
field theory and actually very early in
the history of quantum mechanics people
were already talking about quantum field
theory the
the theory of quantum mechanics where
the number of particles wasn't fixed and
so an early observation was that there
would be vacuum fluctuations just as
there are quantum mechanical
fluctuations uncertainty in energy
whatever else there's also uncertainty
in the number of particles and that led
to the idea of vacuum fluctuations and
lots of other things related to that
but already quantum field theory had
been had originated with people like
heisenberg had worked on it back in the
1920s
and late 1920s
it was known that it was mathematically
very difficult working with quantum
field theory
there was the things called fox spaces
which were invented by
maybe 1930s it's a kind of an idea of uh
it's when you describe a something like
an electron in quantum mechanics you
have a wave function it's a function and
it describes
the um kind of the um
things about probabilities of electrons
if you want to have a field which has a
variable number of particles in it what
you basically have to have is something
where you have this generalization of
functions where you have not just one
function describes one electron one
photon but a sort of a a family of an
arbitrary number of functions and that's
kind of one of the mathematical things
that had to be developed there
but
what happened back going into the 1940s
um was uh
that
well there were a bunch of problems when
people
the theory of electromagnetism the
quantum theory of electromagnetism it
was fairly obvious what its structure
should be
that was obvious by the 1930s that was
pretty obvious
that there would be a description in
terms of by that time it was the iraq
equation which had been mentioned in the
1930s that's the equation for
relativistic electrons
and uh maxwell's equations were alive
and well that had been invented in the
in the late 1800s by james clark maxwell
those are the equations for the
classical electromagnetic field it was
easy to see what the quantum analog of
those should be so when had the quantum
equations for electrons the quantum
equations for the the equations for
electromagnetic field it was quite easy
to see how those should be coupled
together it was quite straightforward to
construct a theory of quantum
electrodynamics to write down what the
theory should be like mathematically to
define its energy function it's
hamiltonian it's thing that describes
the hamiltonian in quantum mechanics is
a thing that also is is a sort of
generator of time evolution so it kind
of tells you how the how a system of
electrons and photons should evolve with
time so that was all pretty well
understood
big problem
the when you tried to compute things in
quantum electrodynamics you've got
infinity is the answer to many kinds of
things fundamental reason is if you have
an electron and let's say an electron is
a sphere of charge
it's the electron has a negative charge
minus one in some units let's say you've
got the sphere of charge it's all
negative charge all the pieces of the
electron they'll just repel each other
because like charges repel so every
electron will just blow up as a result
of being having this sort of charge
that's that's pushing it apart now it
might have some forces that would hold
the electron together people at one time
actually thought vacuum fluctuations
might hold electrons together but that
doesn't work out that way um at least
not in the usual theory of physics
um and but the the key problem was that
the self energy of the electron the the
amount of
energy force associated with the
electron acting on itself
and uh you know one piece of the
electron repelling another piece of the
electron the the size of that energy
increases like one over r where r is
that as
well is proportional to one over r where
r is the radius of the electron so when
the radius of electron goes to zero
that goes to infinity
okay so that's a problem the next
problem was in quantum theory there was
no understanding of how to deal with
particles that weren't point particles
particles that had non-trivial extent
and things like string theory once
started to have an understanding of
extended objects in quantum mechanics
and quantum field theory
more in quantum mechanics initially
there but um uh back in the day
one only knew how to deal with point
particles
and worse than that when one was dealing
with relativity theory dealing with
extended objects and relativity is also
quite complicated because it's kind of
like you accelerate the thing and one
piece of it you know the thing
effectively elongates and how does that
work and it's all very difficult to make
it consistent with relativity but in any
case so you've got an electron and the
claim is to make it consistent with
quantum mechanics value of zero size
uh kind of uh and and yet at zero size
the thing has infinite self energy oops
there's a problem here
okay now in quantum field theory the way
that's represented is you've got an
electron it's tooling along it emits a
virtual photon and then reabsorbs it
again a very short time later and the
rate of emission of virtual photons
increases as the uh
the well the number of possible photons
you can emit as you as you look at sort
of shorter and shorter times between
emission and reabsorption there's kind
of an infinite number of these photons
that can get as as that time goes to
zero the number of these photons goes to
infinity and that again leads to the
same result basically as the classical
result about an infinite self energy
okay so it didn't quantum field theory
didn't immediately solve the infinite
self-energy problem okay so how does
that work
well what happened was this was a
contribution of dick fineman uh richard
feynman a friend of mine from
when he died in 1987 but i knew him for
from probably the
1978 until then
um
and uh the um so
his big contribution
was the idea of renormalization the idea
that yes there is an infinite self
energy associated with the electron but
every electron has all this cloud of
photons around it that's producing all
this big self energy and it's like it's
okay to just say
the the the true bare electron has minus
infinity mass
the um uh but then every electron in
real life has lots of a cloud of photons
around it which is adding sort of a plus
infinity amount of self energy and well
by golly the minus infinity and the plus
infinity cancel out and the real answer
should be just the mass of the electron
okay so dick fireman always thought this
was kind of a cluj
but
the the big thing that happened in
quantum electrodynamics
is it was proved that the number of such
cluuges that you needed to put into
quantum electrodynamics was three there
were three infinities there were three
kind of bare objects you needed to
define and that was enough to kind of
have uh have quantum electrodynamics and
say just got these three weird arbitrary
things that go in there and then you can
have consistent quantum hydrodynamics
that was
not um
so that was understood by the 1940s
1950s maybe for that to be really
understood people were able to start
computing um
the uh
lots of features
of of quantum field theory lots of
predictions from quantum electrodynamics
the anomalous magnetic moment of the
electron was one big one that was
originally computed by julian schwinger
the so-called g minus two uh another one
was the lamb shift the hypo fine
splitting and hydrogen was uh the shift
of a
relativistically quantum field
theoretically
computable shift um i actually know well
i i know willis lam was a long-time user
of our mathematica
system i don't think i ever met him um
but uh the um um so
then
there were these various predictions of
quantum field theory from quantum
mechanical dynamics they worked just
fine
okay meanwhile
in the other part of sort of particle
physics was the weak interactions
so
the characteristic phenomenon there is
nuclear beta decay when
well it even happens with a single
neutron a neutron decays after about a
thousand seconds into a proton an
electron and an anti-neutrino
and so that process the weak force that
was figured out
in um it was it was just not clear i
mean nuclear people like enrico fermi
had worked a lot
on the weak nuclear force and on beta
decay
you know radioactivity there's alpha
decay which is emitting helium nuclei
uh you know two protons two neutrons
nuclear beta decay is a very common type
of uh of radioactivity um that occurs
sort of throughout the periodic table
that was a that was a big thing when
strange particles were discovered uh
things like the k on
things like um uh the the lambda
particle and so on their decays
were associated with a weak weak force
um they can be produced in pairs using
the strong force but they kind of decay
through the weak force so sort of weak
interaction showed up all over the place
actually when i was getting interested
in particle physics back around 1972 um
i was that was my favorite topic was
weak interactions and i wrote this big
thing which you can probably find on the
web when i was about 13 or so which was
this few hundred page
uh whole treatise on weak interactions
so i was rather interested in those
things and i could tell you lots more
about the physics of that
um it's kind of fun for me that there
were
there were processes where i was like
well this might happen in principle you
know it's going to be a long long time
before anybody measures it for example
pi zero the pi zero particle decays in
about ten to the minus 16 seconds
usually into two photons but it can also
decay into a neutrino anti-neutrino pair
and i think i think that's now been
observed
and um that was a thing where to me that
just seemed like far far out in the
distant future when i was first studying
these things there's another one the um
uh k on going to pioneer neutrino to
neutrino i think that's also been
observed now but that seemed like
distant future back when i was studying
these things but those are all examples
of the weak interactions
so question was what produced the weak
interactions the thing that was figured
out in the 1950s uh in the one time that
dick feynman and murray galman two
people i knew fairly well uh actually
collaborated was in this thing called
the v minus a theory of recontractions
and so the question was
when you had weak interaction what
seemed to happen was with with with
electromagnetic interactions there was
sort of plenty of action at a distance
there were virtual photons that could be
exchanged you could have two electrons
that were far away from each other they
would exchange a virtual photon they one
one of these electrons would effectively
affect the other one there would be a
force that was transmitted over a
significant distance
with the weak interactions the distance
over which things were transmitted was
very small it was like it was a point
contact type interaction there was no
there was no extension to it
and so that was kind of so the first
question was well what kind of an
interaction if you were to extend it
what kind of particle might be being
exchanged to make that interaction
happen and photons are so-called vector
particles they have spin one um that's
kind of roughly the number of you know
if you write down their description in
in the mathematics it means that there
is a a a vector like like for example in
in um the electromagnetic field there's
an a mu which is the vector potential
that's the four pattern the vector four
potential um that is a vector kind of
thing when you deal with gravity it's a
tensor field it has it's like g mu u the
metric tensor has two legs two indices
and uh uh for example when you deal with
the higgs particle it's spin zero it has
sort of uh
it has no indices it's just a scalar
object so this notion of scalar vector
tensor these different kinds of
interactions will be mediated by
different kinds of particles axial
vector interactions are ones where
there's uh where an ordinary vector when
you if you reflect the vector you get
you'll you'll get sort of the opposite
vector an axial vector is something like
a a sort of a screw direction where if
you reflect it you kind of still have
the same thing so it's a it's a kind of
a a um it uh
it doesn't it doesn't uh operate under
reflection the way things usually
operate anyway what what feynman and
galman figured out
in maybe 1950s
i don't remember
uh yeah i guess i guess what had
happened was
in
uh nuclear beta decay i think was 1956
it was discovered that parity is
violated that means that if you take
sort of a if you have a picture of what
happens in nuclear beta decay and then
you have a mirror reflected version of
that picture you could tell one of them
is the real nuclear beta decay one of
them is a fake
in electromagnetism you wouldn't be able
to tell that the mirror reflected
version will be as valid as the
non-mirror reflected version but for
weak interactions there's this
phenomenon of parity violation
discovered um
in uh
what was it cobalt 60 decay maybe i'm
not sure but anyway it was it was
discovered and you could describe how it
was discovered it's not so important for
right now
the
parity violation was discovered that
then led to this v minus a theory of um
uh of weak interactions which was sort
of a descriptive theory of weak
interactions so how do we contractions
really happen
well
the idea that sort of emerged was well
maybe there's a thing a w boson that was
kind of the analog of a photon but
instead of it being zero mass as photons
are that leads to uh
an inverse square law of interaction it
would be have some non-zero mass when
you have a non-zero mass particle
exchanged you get this thing called the
yokawa potential named after heideki
yokawa who in the 1930s proposed that
the way nuclei are held together is by
the exchange of pions uh between or he
didn't know they were called pions yet
but that's what they became called um
between protons that's kind of a more
primitive theory than modern qcd
somewhat equivalent but but basically
that when you have a massive particle
exchange the potential is e to the minus
mu r or the whole thing divided by r so
it has an exponential as well as the
inverse square like term so it dies off
very rapidly it can be it can be a
potential that's that's substantial
substantial force at very short
distances but then it dies off very
quickly so what was conjectured was in
the weak interactions there might be a w
boson that
was uh was um
was the thing being exchanged back in
the early 1970s it was called usually
the intermediate vector boson and it was
all a bit mysterious it wasn't clear how
it worked
but that was kind of an idea
now
what had happened was in 1967 uh steve
weinberg wrote a
very short paper called the model of
leptons
leptons are things like electrons
neutrinos and so on
and he had this idea that one could at
least describe the the weak uh nuclear
the weak force
in terms of
a
um
oh i have to explain one more thing uh
sorry okay let me explain one more thing
so back in 1956 i think
uh
uh yang and mills cng and i think robert
mills
um
sian yang was a pretty famous physicist
who'd been involved in
among other things the suggestion that
parity violation might happen along with
the business called td lee
and uh lee and yang were were kind of a
power pair
of physicists um
uh particularly in the 1950s and so on
um and uh anyway
yang and mills
had this idea
of so-called yang mills what's now
called yang mills theory
uh
the idea was more or less this so we
have electromagnetism
where we've got electrons and they're
charged particles and they exchange
photons
what
you can think about that this was known
um
much earlier i was known to people like
herman vile
that you could think of that
as uh what's called the gauge theory
oh boy let's see how do we how do i get
through this and without having to go
too deep into how that works
essentially
okay here's a way to understand this
um
imagine you have an electron
it has
it is producing an electric field
if you
the the field lines of the electric
field kind of go out from the electron
like a hedgehog
they're they're kind of they're all
pointing out in in radial direction
everywhere
okay you've got your electron so another
thing comes by oh it sees that there's
an electric field line there's an
electrical force associated with that
i'm going to be deflected whatever else
okay now i imagine you move the electron
okay
so
eventually the electron will be a
hedgehog in a new place and it'll have
new field lines coming out
so the question is as you move this
electron
what uh there's there's you have to
think what happens to those field lines
that are coming out from the electron if
you if you're far away from the electron
eventually those field lines have to
readjust themselves but if
after a very short time you you wouldn't
know that the electron has moved what
happens is at the speed of light there's
this kind of change in the field lines
that has to happen to deal with the fact
that eventually the field line's going
to be different
so you can think of that process
of sort of the way the field lines have
to change there's sort of an inevitable
change
in as you move electrons around there's
something that inevitably changes and
you can kind of you can kind of
understand that inevitable change by
having this idea of of having sort of
the the sort of inevitably this uh this
gauge field it's called that is
associated with sort of this change of
of uh
this this
sort of notifying the world of what
changed with the electron this is a very
rough description but that's sort of why
inevitably when there's things like
charge there is inevitably this kind of
gauge field in the case of
electromagnetism it's associated with
photons that's kind of telling that is
is necessary to kind of tell the world
what happens with these charged
particles and sort of make everything uh
work out correctly in terms of what
their fields do and so on so it's sort
of an inevitable feature of having
charged particles that you have these
sort of a gauge field that is associated
with kind of
uh describing uh the
making consistency about changes in what
happens with charged particles okay the
the fancy words for all of this they can
define covariant derivatives you can
define um
connections on these fiber bundles that
represent
the
well never mind this is this is
the connection of all that stuff of
fiber bundles and things like that
became very big um around uh mid 1970s
uh for various reasons that was that was
later in this story
um
back in the in the days of yangon mills
the what they realized was you could
have
a charge other than the ordinary charge
like electric charge you could have a
charge that wasn't just a scalar charge
where you just say the charge is plus
one it's minus one it's 0.5 it's 2.7
just a scalar number you could have a
charge that was sort of had a direction
associated with it was like a vector
and you could have such charges
and where you could have a charge where
you say it's more like a a charge a
color charge and of course that comes up
again in qcd where sort of they're all
different colors can be different sort
of shades of what charge you have
okay so you can represent this idea of
what kind of charge you have by saying
in addition to the value of the charge
there's also a direction
and you can represent that kind of thing
by in terms of group theory by saying
that in addition to the if it's just a
scalar it's you don't need any groups
but when you have so group theory is
talking about sort of the the
transformations that you can make on
something like you might have a rotation
group that says
that there's a set of that that has
contains all the various transformations
you can make on something in
three-dimensional space that's a group
called so3 the special orthogonal group
with uh in three dimensions um that's
equivalent to the group more or less
equivalent to the group su-2
and the group su-2 the special unitary
group um that
is of size two matrices that's the sort
of mathematical description but
basically it's like as if you have a
vector that this charge that has vectors
associated with it okay when you do that
there is similarly a gauge theory but
the gauge theory has
um
uh instead of having photon like things
has things that sort of have uh that
have sort of vector information in them
uh what
and so what yang mills proposed is that
you could have
a
gauge theory that would involve things
other than just sort of scalar charges
and in particular so-called non-abelian
gauge theory is a theory where the
groups
oh boy this is uh okay so when you have
a transformation in a group uh you could
say
let's say you're you're um uh you're
just rotating around a circle you say
you rotate by 20 degrees you rotate by
30 degrees doesn't matter whether you do
20 degrees first then 30 degrees 30
degrees first then 20 degrees
that's called nobelian that means that
the group of the circle called u1 is an
abelian group
uh if you on the other hand when you
deal with rotations of a sphere it
matters in which order you do the
rotations you'll get a different answer
if you rotate it one way rather than the
other it's kind of like a rubik's cube
type story it matters which in which
order you do the transformations that's
a so-called non-abelian group su 2 is a
non-abelian group
so what yang mills proposed is that
there might be non-abelian gauge
theories they thought of that as a
possible theory for strong interactions
and things to do with pions and so on
they weren't imagining other kinds of
things what steve weinberg did was to
suggest that su-2 the sort of su-2 gauge
theory might be what was relevant for
weak interactions and it's a little
complicated because the uh
electromagnetism is a is a u1 gauge
theory um
the uh
uh what steve weinberg suggested was
that weak contractions are like an su-2
gauge theory but it isn't quite like
just the weak interactions and just the
electromagnetic interactions it's a bit
messier than that there's kind of a
mixing between the effects of photons
and the effects of w bosons and so that
led to a thing called the weinberg angle
um let's see sine
squared theta w is about 0.35 as i
remember correctly i remember correctly
um and actually i remember computing
that in some model
uh
yeah the um
in any case you can you can work out
so what what the original 1967 paper uh
talked about was su 2 cross u1 gauge
theory
and that was a theory of leptons things
like electrons and neutrinos those
things have electromagnetic forces
electromagnetic interactions and weak
interactions but do not have strong
interactions so it was a theory of how
those things worked using su 2 cross c1
gauge theory okay so that was that idea
and
it
uh an abdus salam who i also knew but
not as not not particularly well
um was also involved and i don't know
the whole history of all the various
papers that got written about that
but there were predictions
from
the weinberg salaam model
for example there was a prediction that
there will be so-called neutral currents
in addition to the w particle which was
the mediator of of nuclear beta decay in
nuclear beta decay ordinarily the charge
of the particles that are decaying would
change it would be well they would still
be conserved but you would go from
something like
um
a
an electron could turn into a neutrino
emitting a charged w particle which
could then turn another neutrino into an
electron for example that was the the
most standard form of beta decay
involved the so-called charge currents
where you would have uh a charged
particle that was the the intermediate
vector boson as it was first called but
that theory predicted that there should
also be neutral currents a particle that
was a partner of the w particle um and
or a partner of this intermediate vector
boson which nobody really knew existed
that would be was later called the zero
and it was discovered oh boy uh after i
was out of the business so it was
discovered sometime in the 80s
um although neutral currents were
discovered earlier in that neutral
currents were discovered
in
1973 or four
um
the the particle that mediated them was
discovered much later but the the
existence of neutral currents
was discovered um in around 1974 as a
matter of fact experiments that would
have discovered neutral currents were
done in the early 1960s but nobody was
looking for neutral parents at that time
and so they were not they weren't
noticed and actually worse than that the
bubble chamber film that was just a
method for doing particle physics
experiments
had been thrown away by the time people
cared about neutral currents so they
couldn't go back and look at that old
data and uh and find neutral currents in
it but any case that then then what
happened
is that so there's this theory it had
the prediction of neutral currents
it said okay there's this w bozon zebos
on it predicted those should exist
and then the question was could you pull
the same trick that dick fireman had
pulled in quantum electrodynamics for
these non-ability engaged theories could
you could you say yes they have this
normalization feature too
or or not and the most naive way of
looking at them didn't look promising
they didn't look like they had
realizability just with w bosons and
electrons and so on you've got all kinds
of infinities you don't get a finite
number of infinities you've got an
infinite number of infinities bad news
for example the the well it was known by
well by when i was getting into well
let's see
uh yeah i was knowing that um
uh one feature
that's already a kind of a bit of a a
weird feature is that usually particle
interactions get less
strong the higher the energy of the
interacting particles that's not quite
true but it's true of lots of lots of
interactions the
for for weak interactions they got
stronger so a higher energy neutrino
uh
is easier to stop than a lower energy
neutrino like low energy and trinomials
can go all the way through the earth
but higher energy neutrinos get stopped
quite quickly and that that's one of the
pieces that sort of contributed to the
apparent
inability to use this renormalization
trick in weak interaction so it was the
initial thing was
realizability isn't going to work you're
not going to be able to compute things
using quantum field theory with weak
interactions with the weinberg salaam
model et cetera et cetera et cetera okay
but there was a there was a fix
everything would work fine if all the
particles in the weinberg salaam model
had zero mass
absolutely fine all renormalization
worked fine it's all good the problem
with that is obviously electrons don't
have zero mass neutrinos have quite
small mass the time it looked like they
might have zero mass photons have zero
mass but the electrons don't and the w
particles definitely don't
so there was a problem
well it turned out
that back in 1964 or so
there had been a proposal made of what's
called spontaneous symmetry breaking as
the higgs mechanism there were a number
of other people uh
um brought angler to various other
people
i knew at least slightly all these
people
um
there had been
this suggestion made
that
okay imagine there's another particle a
higgs particle
and
let's say that it could interact with
all other particles
um
and
imagine that throughout the universe
there is a
an average
the um
uh
there's a density of higgs field
throughout the universe the whole
universe is full of higgs field
but every higgs particle can interact
with other particles so the higgs this
higgs field can interact with all these
particles so in a sense an electron
every every time the electron exists in
the universe it's going through this
this kind of density of higgs particles
higgs field in the universe and it keeps
on interacting with the six field it
turns out that can be the equivalent of
the electron having a mass
effectively the presence of a vacuum
expectation value as it's called the
vacuum density of higgs field can
can provide effective mass to electrons
and things so the idea was that let's
have something where
the um
um
where the the the kind of the um
um
the we it's sort of it seems like a
cheat at first you say imagine we have a
higgs field
which can have higgs particles
associated with it imagine we have a
fake field and imagine that the coupling
between the higgs field and an electron
has some value the coupling between the
higgs field and the muon has some value
imagine that that coupling is 206 times
bigger for the muon
well then that will imply that the
effective mass of the muon is 206 times
larger than the effective mass of the
electron but it seems like a clue
because you're saying i'm putting in
this coupling and that's what's giving
me the mass well the mass has to come
from somewhere so maybe that's not quite
such a kludge but any case the higgs
mechanism was this idea of imagine
there's this extra higgs field and
imagine that it develops a vacuum
expectation value that throughout the
universe
that there isn't uh that there's this
because of the self-interaction of the
his particle it is has an instability
that causes there to be a non-zero value
of the higgs field
um and that's kind of that was the higgs
mechanism
and it was you know it was taken
reasonably seriously it was like i hope
it doesn't work this way because it kind
of seems like a cluj but it's taken
reasonably seriously um then actually i
worked on this um uh in the early
universe this whole higgs mechanism
would self-destruct because at high
temperatures this condensate this vacuum
value of the higgs field disappears
and so with a person called rocky cold
who has had a long career mostly
university of chicago in cosmology uh
back in 1979 i wrote this paper about
the expansion rate of the early universe
and realized that as a result of kind of
the destruction of the higgs
field in the very early universe
there would be a change in the expansion
rate of the early universe but it was
kind of relegated to a footnote the
universe would expand exponentially
and that would solve various problems
but i didn't take it very seriously
because
it for all kinds of reasons i didn't
think that the universe would be able to
sort of survive in this state where it
could where it was kind of unstable with
respect to to nucleation of sort of
expansion of various different kinds it
was then taken much more seriously by
people like alan guth who kind of
originated this uh inflationary universe
scenario which is all about taking that
idea seriously and now unfortunately
that that whole model has become
incredibly complicated by the time you
you hear about you know inflatons and
lots of different kinds of particles and
so on it's definitely not going the way
that successful models go which is you
you know you just learn more from the
model you don't have to add more stuff
to the model
uh the good news is kind of our modern
theory of physics
um has a very different explanation of
how the early universe works and starts
infinite dimensional and gradually cools
down to being three-dimensional that i
think removes all of these issues it
preserves some of the kind of concept of
inflation but in a completely different
way with respect to dimension rather
than with respect to inflaton fields and
things like this but in any case that's
that's relevant to this historical
narrative
but anyway so higgs field
it was it was a thing the higgs particle
hadn't been discovered people didn't
know if it existed um but uh then the
question was
if you had so massless young mills
theory massless and honorably engaged
theory renormalizable you could
calculate things but when you had an
actual mass of electrons didn't work
what about spontaneously broken
uh non-obelion gauge theories that is
things which had the higgs mechanism in
them well maybe you would preserve
realizability
that was figured out by gerhard at hoft
in
1970 um
three or four
along with tiny veltman his advisor who
had been very much involved in sort of
making computer algebra systems
for for doing particle physics
calculations um
i wrote an obituary piece about teen
development fairly recently
but in any case that was the that was
the moment where renormalizability of
spontaneously broken gauge theories was
established and so that kind of gave
spontaneously broken gauge theories and
the weinberg still arm theory kind of
the stamp of approval of yes you can
calculate things in this theory it it's
still impossible to calculate things
even without that but there were sort of
pathologies that were lurking in the
corners um that uh uh seemed to blow
things up
so anyway that that's some uh see the
question have been about um
um
the higgs mechanism and and peter higgs
and steve weinberg and so on um that was
that was by the um
i would say by
uh well then the big thing that happened
in 1973 was the discover of discovery of
asymptotic freedom and qcd
by um
uh
three people i know um
david [ __ ] sir frank wilcheck and and
david gross
um
that was uh
and sydney coleman had been
uh quite involved in that also a
president harvard along with along with
um david politzer um
and the other two were at princeton
um
that was uh the discovery that the
quantum field theory applied to the
theory of quarks and gluons which hadn't
been taken very seriously up to that
time because it seemed like it's all
about strong interactions you can't
compute things et
et cetera what was discovered at that
time and actually gerhard huffed had
figured out something similar probably
slightly earlier but hadn't really
internalized its importance
um the uh that it was uh that it was a
theory where uh in the opposite where
the kind of the higher the energy
the weaker the effect of interaction so
that meant when you had particle
interactions at very high energies qcd
would behave like a theory where things
were weakly interacting where you could
compute a lot of stuff and so that
started a giant industry that kind of
had ramped up by about 1976. i i kind of
worked in that industry for a few years
and because it was a very new industry i
was able to compute a bunch of things
people hadn't computed before and also i
had the kind of secret weapon of using
computers to do it and so um that was uh
that was a fun thing but um uh that was
so qcd was sort of the the other
component that became the standard model
so i mentioned that electromagnetism is
like a u1 gauge theory suv2 gauge theory
is kind of like the weak interactions
it's a little bit mixed together with
electromagnetism uh qcd theory of quarks
and gluons this idea of color charge
color charge is an su-3 charge um that's
a that's a charge associated with sort
of a three-directional ish kind of thing
not quite that's not quite the way it
works um but so the end result is the
standard model is an su 3 cross su 2
across u1 spontaneously broken gauge
theory and it kind of tells you the sc3
cross sp2 cross u1 where he tells you
the basic structure of the of the theory
then you have to add in the higgs
mechanism and that was kind of the um uh
the the extra piece there
i think um
um
yeah so that's that's the story of that
now steve weinberg i can i can say more
about about quite a lot more about him
uh i hadn't really met him when i was
back doing particle physics because i
had been at caltech
and uh an institute for advanced
studying in princeton and at caltech one
of the sort of big figures was murray
gulmann who was the inventor of quarks
among other things and murray
uh
had various kinds of negative
interactions with people one of those
people with steve weinberg who refused
to ever visit caltech so i didn't happen
to meet him there but um the uh
i he had written he was a is a good
expositor um and had written
a book called gravitational cosmology
that was a nice textbook of those things
that i read back in 1976 or so when i
was getting interested in the
relationship between particle physics
and cosmology was a nice book um a very
very much of a i would say 19th century
mathematical methods
book applied to more modern physics
and i have to say i think that um
when steve
weinberg died he'd just written a
textbook about sort of undergraduate
introduction to theoretical physics and
i was looking at it nice book but it's
19th century mathematics again it's it's
very much the kind of a certain style of
doing physics that i would say
originated probably with people like
maxwell um in the late 1800s and kind of
continued through
a certain amount of of the of the things
i mean dick feynman was was also into
this kind of physics that was sort of
mathematical physics done with
essentially 19th century mathematics
you know where special functions like
the poly logarithm functions and so on
are your personal friends actually i'm
not sure the poly logarithm function's
always a bit exotic that fireman was
into those nobody really knew quite what
to call them i'm not sure steve weinberg
was a poly logarithms person so much a
lot of physicists have their own sort of
favorite special functions um the but
but steve weinberg was very much that
that style of physicist
i i am he was also
a substantial user of our um wolfram
language mathematica system
uh uh
he he did many things contributed a lot
to physics i remember murray gullman uh
always used to say about him in a little
bit of a put down he would say you know
steve weinberg is the person who uh he
uh if you want to compute something he's
the guy who knows how to compute
anything
like the particular example he gave was
you want somebody to compute the
viscosity of milk ask steve weinberg
so in any case the um
uh when i started working on um well i
guess steve weinberg ended up writing a
review of my new kind of science book
that was not a particularly well
considered piece um and which i think i
i now understand from understanding the
extent to which he was really a kind of
19th century mathematical physicist it's
like this is alien
and i think that's kind of what what he
concluded i remember i had lunch with
him after after that came out and he was
like i didn't really understand that
what you were doing was sort of a new
kind of science as opposed to
what we have been doing before and it's
like well actually the title of the book
was a new kind of science and although
you might have ignored that title as you
know
uh hyperbolo
hyperbole you know that was saying the
main point which is it's a new kind of
science it's not the same kind of
science it's not the same kind of way of
thinking about things the same kind of
way making conclusions the same kind of
raw material as you're used to from
mathematical physics he's like okay i
guess i get it type thing
um i think um
i do fault him for not being enough of a
student of the history of science to
realize that they are kind of paradigm
shifts that happen and um to uh to kind
of uh imagine that he couldn't be seeing
such a thing
but i i i saw him in subsequent years
um and i i would tell him about the the
you know that i intended at some point
to try and do this sort of big assault
on a final of a fundamental theory of
physics and he was like oh it's never
gonna work it's never gonna work you
know we know physics is continuous and
space is continuous and so on and he
said um uh you know eventually he said
please don't do that project
why not
well because if you succeed it will
destroy what we've done in physics for
the last 50 years
and i said i'm really sure that's not
going to happen
you know the what we'll find and the way
i would describe it today is kind of a
machine code that lives underneath the
level of the kind of physics that's been
done for the last 50 years i don't think
i had quite such an uh a kind of
uh kind of colorful way to describe it
back then
but that's more or less what i said
um and uh so he was not um
i think i i wrote up a um
um
thing about the background to our
physics project and i had a section
whose title was quotes please don't do
that project that was a quote from steve
weinberg
so
that's um
that's that
let's see let's see if i can find a few
more particle physics questions here
since i'm on to talking about particle
physics
uh the question from parmenides did i
ever meet bryce dewitt sadly i did not
um
the uh
let's see
the question from david what was
feynman's opinion of supersymmetry
i don't think he cared about it i'm
trying to think if i ever saw him
interact with super symmetry at all
i mean back when i was at caltech
in the late um
1970s early 1980s
um
the uh
uh there was some
there was some enthusiasm for super
cemetery there were people who was
called pfield glanis ferrar these were
both people working on sort of the the
consequence of super symmetry also a
person called lars brink who was a um
uh
person involved with string theory which
had by that time
kind of merged a bit with supersymmetry
um and also um
uh
certainly people like bruno zamino who
was berkeley i think at that time
um if i remember correctly maybe still
at cern i'm not sure
um were big sort of super symmetry
people murray gelman was quite a super
symmetry enthusiast and it was a basic
rule of thumb that anything murray
gilman was enthusiastic about dick
feinman would not be enthusiastic about
i mean they spent many years with
officers basically next to each other
and um having
you know they each told me all kinds of
uh sort of terrible intellectual slurs
on the other so to speak um so it was it
was one of those cases where
sometimes that kind of energy that kind
of uh sort of
interaction produces better results i'm
not sure it particularly did in this
case i remember when when feynman was
working on
sort of consequences of
qcd uh
uh qcd had been a theory that murray had
been quite involved in um and uh uh you
know he was like he was so disgusted by
how messy the stuff dick feynman was
doing was and so on and um uh dick
feinman was kind of like oh murray has
got all his sort of mathematical this
and that's and they don't they don't
really connect to anything type thing so
i think i think dick fineman would have
viewed supersymmetry i think as kind of
one of those mathematical thingy dingies
that he doesn't really understand and
doesn't really care about uh that's what
i think i mean there may be maybe
evidence to the to the contrary but um
that's that would be my impression
um
there's a question from communities
about some does our physics project deal
with gravitons and how to avoid
non-illinois it's it's a completely
different story there the the um the
emergence of quantum field theory is an
emergent property and the whole question
of normalizability is sort of moot when
you have a discrete underlying structure
to space
the question whether you can probe that
structure by using features that sort of
probe the infinities is an interesting
question and actually i should think
about that thank you for that meta
suggestion there
um
oh gosh there's a question from uh
daver
about kalabi yao manifolds and
visualizations and string theory and so
on
um i think it's going to take me fairly
far afield to talk about that and to
talk about i'll be talking about
uh sort of symmetries and and solutions
to einstein's equations and and so on
maybe another time i'll talk about that
um
uh there's a question from pawneeties
about some
millennial problem probably created by
my friend arthur jaffe um
uh this was uh uh landon clay was a um
uh
a person who had a investment company in
boston who um created this thing called
the clay mathematics institute and its
first director was arthur jaffe a long
time uh mathematical physics professor
at harvard
who had this idea of sort of raising the
awareness of the whole thing by
inventing a small number of millennium
problems which would be kind of problems
in math uh around the year i guess it
must have been around the year 2000 it
really that long ago well i'm not sure i
think it was a little after 2000. um
that um
uh would kind of serve a little bit the
analog of hilbert's 23 problems that he
proposed in 1900 at um that kind of are
things where people get a lot of a lot
of points for i've solved the hilbert
problem
um and you know hilbert's tenth problem
or something the the unsolvability of of
um of different time equations equations
involving integers that was sort of a
big deal solved in the 1960s and so on
and uh the um um
it um
uh
it was um
um
was i going to say the the um
um
this that so i forget how many
millennium problems there are half a
dozen or so they're all sort of they're
pretty well known problems in
mathematics and mathematical physics
um i think one of the problems in
the the the the problem is stated in
young mills theory is the problem of the
mass gap of yang mills theory which is
more or less
the question of um
whether quarks and gluons or things like
them are permanently confined
or can escape as free particles but
that's a that's can be
stated as a mathematical problem about
young mills theory about sort of pure
yang mills theory just a theory of
gluons um without quarks and things in
it um and that's what one of those
problems is
uh all right i think i'm i'm being told
that
we ran out of time here um
uh
a lot of lovely questions here
that um i very much look forward to
addressing
um
the next time
so i think we should wrap up here for
now
and uh so i'm actually about to do
another
live stream that's part of my day job
working on uh uh software design
so um uh but uh for here
for this some
q a
let's wrap up